welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast on this
week's episode I was joined by Amber
Penrose I absolutely loved uncovering
how Amber has become a top performer in
her business doing Circa 800 Grand in a
permanent market and we discussed it all
I'm looking in a confidence per day plan
how she wins clients how she's built her
brand online you name it you're going to
learn everything that you need to become
a top performer in this episode Amber
welcome to the podcast thank you for
having me really looking forward to
unpacking your journey I've been someone
that's enjoyed your content from afar
I've got some post ready that I want to
dissect with you oh God uh all good
things
but as as you know where we like to
start with this podcast is with the
million pound question that I'd love to
get your take on but before we do that
and before we talk about uh this journey
that you're currently on and the things
that you've learned the challenges along
the way
I just want to give everyone a bit of
context in terms of where you're at on
your recruitment Journey so anything
that I miss that you did really
important
let me know just butt in okay so yeah so
so you've been in uh so you are in your
fifth year of recruitment yeah in a
month's time is my fifth anniversary
feels like 50 years but
here we go
so so five five years in recruitment I
think you were quite honest with me in
terms of
the first yeah 18 months first year you
did found uh really difficult
and I think over the last three years
you've really progressed you're now a
director of Life Sciences
um at the Irving night group so uh this
is what I want to make sure I've got
correctly but right now you manage a
team of seven yeah that's right eight
eight including me one's remote and then
the remaining six they're in Leeds with
me
and you are also someone that is uh
striving for or I'm not sure if you
currently hold the the top biller
um status within your business but I
know that's uh been a big goal of yours
but as well as managing you've also been
focusing on leveling up your Billings
year on year and I think you shared to
me that your best year in bidding so far
you're a perm consultant uh was just
under 800 Grand at 780k
um in a year and I think as well just to
add a bit more context to that for
people is I think you shared to me that
around 40
um of the business and Partnerships uh
that you work on tend to be retained and
then 60 tend to be uh contingent
exclusive and you do a lot of business
with repeat customers but over the last
two years as well as hitting those sorts
of numbers and having those sorts of
performances you have been in this
leadership role over the last two years
and that's been a whole journey for you
uh as well yep that's absolutely right I
need you on my BD calls as my master
there we go so why why don't we start
with a million pound question and I'd
love to get your take on this so what
what's Amber's perspective on what you
believe are the common characteristics
and traits that make up a high
performing recruiter in today's market
and I love this question and I think
everyone that you have on the podcast
has a slightly different answer and I
think so for me when I'm interviewing
particularly graduates the thing I am
looking for is passion
I don't care what you're passionate
about you do not need to be passionate
about recruitment right I don't think
many of us come out of the womb thinking
oh my God I want to be a recruiter this
is my dream you can be passionate about
Trainspotting for all I care I just want
you to
have that fire in your belly because
in this job right that pertains to when
you speak to candidates you need to be
passionate about the role that you're
hiring for what it pertains to when you
speak to clients you need to be
passionate about the work that you do it
pertains to your personal brand you need
to be passionate about yourself and your
abilities and I think passion is one
trait that is inherent it's somewhat
uncoachable
um and it's not something you can kind
of gain over the years so I think
particularly with grads that's really
something that's a priority for me when
I'm hiring
resilience that always bloody comes off
on your podcast but I think it is so
important and in particular you know
mental resilience and again when you're
a graduate right you're thrown into this
world of recruitment where you may have
been struggling to afford ready meals
for the past three years and all of a
sudden you wake up on a on a Friday on
payday and you've got 10 grand in your
account and
it can be hard you know when you've got
these fees and
you're focusing on them so much so I
think the ability to be resilient and
just disconnect yourself from the
outcome focus on the relationships focus
on building your network and focus on
the job at hand and do not focus on the
end goal because I've had so many people
on my team that are you know in their
second week they've just spoken to a
client they haven't even started
headhunting and they're sat there
calculating you know what their fee is
going to be and what commission they're
going to get and I just think oh my God
stop that
expectations lead to disappointment
um so I think just being able to shut
off get on with the job and forget about
the outcome it is just imperative to get
through because it can't be tough at
times
um so yeah passion and resilience and
also again I think when you listen to
any CEO and anyone that comes on your
podcast that's been successful in
recruitment they're obsessed with
bettering themselves they're obsessed
with reading books they're obsessed with
listening to podcasts they're obsessed
with self-development
and I think that's imperative you need
to you know think Beyond The Four Walls
of your agency because there's only so
much you can learn within that scope
um so someone that's passionate about
reading and being a bit of a geek that's
also a big check in my book
love it so why don't we just start then
by talking about the early years of
Amber's career because I've got a couple
of notes here when we're prepared for
this yeah
um because I found it quite interesting
learning about your uh initial uh yeah
the early part of your journey so I
think you was it was quite fair with me
that yeah you found it difficult
but what um I thought was absolutely
crazy which you can share with me if you
think ended up being a positive or
actually a real challenge was I think
I've got it here that in your first nine
months you did 190 Grand
which was a blessing and a curse for
sure because
again 22 year old Amber who was
incredibly passionate didn't have many
self-limiting beliefs to be honest I
landed a CCO role as my first hire and
it was just the biggest hindrance
looking back I thought oh my God this is
easy what's everyone complaining about
like why isn't everyone a recruiter I
bloody love this job
um and looking back I don't know why I
said that I'm pretty sure my boss sold
the retainer for me to be honest as well
but we moved we don't need to know that
um
but yeah I first 18 months were great
but again I think I just became
complacent I got lucky and I think in
your first year and I always say this to
my team do not compare yourself to
anyone else within your first year
because yes of course A lot of it comes
down to skill but really 50 of it in
that first year is a lot of luck and you
know being in the right place at the
right time
and I think that's exactly what happened
to me so that's why after those 18
months when I'd had such a successful
time and you know one top newcomer
I really really struggled because I
hadn't really mastered all of the
processes I'd just fallen into the right
place at the right time as I mentioned
um and then I really had to look at
myself and think
Amber you're not actually that good at
recruitment you've just got really lucky
um so whilst it was amazing for my bank
account as a poor graduate that had just
come out of working at Subway for two
years it was terrible for my progress
yeah I hear this a lot I guess what what
I'd love to get your thoughts on because
I did jot that down around the luck
piece so I'm a big believer that you can
absolutely create your own luck so why
don't you share your thoughts on
if you have that Mantra internally of
look uh if yeah 50 like don't compare
yourself in the first year
don't focus on outcomes 50 of the first
year can actually be down to luck so how
can people listen to this create more
luck in their first year do you think
what are some of the things that they
need to be focusing on doing rather than
focusing on uh the outcomes yeah and and
don't get me wrong I don't want people
to take that in the wrong way because
saying it's based on luck is not
particularly motivating and whilst I was
very lucky I was also working 12 hours a
day I was you know missing out on plans
with my friends and I was on my emails
at 11 PM at night and my friends are
like Amber what are you doing like get
off your phone you're obsessed
um so whilst a lot of it is like you
create your luck right if I'm just
sitting there and not posting anything
on LinkedIn not getting my visibility
out there of course these opportunities
aren't going to come my way
so I think it's kind of a damaging
mindset to have slightly
um
but again I was in a really really
difficult you know Market which was
really difficult to understand so I
mainly in biotech right now and I have
no kind of biotechnology background
besides the fact that I'm diabetic and I
use the technology myself every day but
I do not understand the intricacies of
it whatsoever
um
so yeah I think I think you create the
luck right for yourself and I think
ultimately this job comes down to to
hard work and putting that hard work
into the right places I was building my
brand from day one and that's always
been something that's been imperative to
me so I think
that's probably created a lot of the
luck as well because the visibility has
been there since day one
let's break that down a bit then what
does that actually look like how is
Amber building her brand and investing
in your visibility early on what did
that actually look like was you sharing
content on LinkedIn would you actively
growing your network what what does that
actually look like
so I look at recruitment in a different
way I
just build relationships so I think in
my business
like that's all I can speak about but we
focus a lot on outbound messaging
outbound emailing you know
speculative candidates whereas I wanted
to look at this job differently and
think okay if I can genuinely build
friendships within this Market that's
gonna serve me well good things happen
to good people right and it has I now
have coffee dates with clients and I
have clients that set me up with their
friends that have you know tips about
diabetes or tips about mental health and
just focusing on relationships besides
you know outbound messaging I think has
been imperative for me and
it's a long game right I do not want to
look at recruitment as a short-term game
because yes sending out an unsolicited
candidate is great and it might amount
in a quick fee but I'm never going to
work with that client again if anything
I'm going to piss them off because I've
been flooding their inbox with
candidates that they didn't even ask for
um so I think focusing on relationships
rather than outcomes and fees has been
imperative and you've got to do that
from day one yeah absolutely have to and
I think building a brand as well has
been
instrumental for me on LinkedIn for
inbound leads and that's something that
I've been passionate about since day one
posting three times a week without fail
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday 8 A.M I'm
there I'm visible people know I'm Little
Mix recruiter and they come to me and
they suggest me because I'm everywhere
on LinkedIn
um so yeah I'd love to get your take on
what are Amber's beliefs around
the principles to building a great
relationship
honesty
passion
right if you get on a business
development recall with a recruiter and
they're bored you can see it in their
face they do not want to be there all
they're going to tell you about is their
CRM that every single other recruiter
needs uses as well you know
I just think show a bit of excitement
show that you want to be there ask some
genuine questions that get them thinking
whenever I have a BD call my aim is for
the client to say hmm great question or
hmm I've never been asked that question
before I love that yeah you want to look
for their feedback you want to
be memorable do not be a corporate robot
and I think that's the mistake that I
made at the start particularly you know
because I work in exact search in a
biotech realm I thought oh my God
there's these CEOs that have phds in
molecular biology I'm a 22 year old
graduate who's just came out of Subway
for two years I don't know what I'm
talking about but if I show passion and
show that I care and show that I'm
excited about their business that's
going to get me way further than just
coming on and being like hi I'm an
executive recruiter working in executive
Search like everyone else does
um
so yeah
no that's that's really great and I
guess you sort of spoke a bit about it
there but I definitely wanted to ask you
so if there's anything else you want to
add or
there's anything practically that really
helps you but like you said you was it
went from Subway asking people what what
type of bread they wanted
to speak into
c-suite people in
biotech companies a lot of people would
massively put these people on a pedestal
and sort of the sort of self dialogue
might sound like wow what what value can
I give this person or like why would
they give me time or like they're some
of the things that you might say to
yourself so I know a lot of people
really struggle with this when they go
on to this sort of Business Development
Journey or they Maybe started as a sort
of delivery consultant and then they're
transition to a 360 uh recruiter so is
there anything else that you can add
there that practically might help people
listening to this that are just maybe
finding themselves yeah putting people
up putting clients and the people they
speak to a bit of an uh pedestal and
almost maybe having a bit of an imposter
syndrome uh show up and not really
having conviction or understanding the
value that they can bring is there
anything else that helps you yeah I
think an imposter Syndrome has been a
huge attribute throughout my life and it
definitely was when I started with
business development course and like you
said it's terrifying you're often a new
graduate and you're shoved onto a CEO
Business Development call on your first
day of the job and it's tough It's
daunting but I think you just have to
remember that they're just people they
are just people
and the sooner that you realize that and
that everyone gets nervous okay that
they might even be nervous to have this
call with you they might be nervous
about finding the right recruiter and
this is a really big priority for them
so again just remembering that they're
people with interests and dislikes and
stories and uncovering those stories as
well and just remembering to use your
ears 80 and use your mouth 20 I think
was imperative for me as well because I
think what I thought would make me
appear knowledgeable in reality isn't I
thought that I needed to blurt out all
of this biological information and prove
to them that I understood the technology
when in reality all I needed to
understand was their pain points and how
to solve that
and once you really simplify the process
the BD process I think it becomes so
much less daunting and more enjoyable
and now I genuinely hand on heart love
Business Development it's my absolute
favorite part of the job
um but I think it's all mind over matter
it's a mindset switch and it definitely
comes with time don't get me wrong I was
not confident until quite recently
honestly
um so give yourself time you don't need
to be everything all at once and if you
need your manager to you know come on
and help you with those business
development at the calls at the start so
be it and a big thing for me that's
really really helped is since day one I
record every single one of my BDS I've
had to get a new phone to get more
storage on it recently and I look back
at the ones that I did in year one and I
cringe
like how
um but it's been imperative for me to
learn you know I write notes on what I
could have done better what I missed out
and then for the next call I can add
that and learn and grow from each
mistake that I make
so if you do that I've got a definitely
I've got a question on that oh God so I
firstly I think that's amazing uh it
does
absolutely baffle me the amount of
recruitment companies that don't enable
their concerns to have some sort of
phone system to have those learning
opportunities like the amount of
recruitment companies that still have
their recruiters like just using mobile
phone and I that was that was definitely
me when I was in recruitment it's just a
huge missed opportunity
to learn improve develop
so the question I have for you which I
think people would love me to ask right
now
is what would be the main differences
that we would hear on Amber's BD calls
early on
to more recently and more now what would
be some of the fundamental differences
that we feel
are helping you get more out of
the business development or yeah getting
more out of it what would be some of the
main differences you think if we were to
listen to Amber's in the first year to
Amber more recently
Okay thousands of things
um
it just gave me like the top things at
the top of mind sorry sorry I just I
know that I'm sure there's loads but
yeah things that are top of mind when I
asked that
so 2018 Amber Business Development calls
were all about me it was III Irving like
this Irving night that I'm a recruiter
in this I'm a creature in that whereas
now I want to eradicate I from my
vocabulary it's all about them it's
about their pain points it's about their
Journey it's about why did you take the
call with me today what are you looking
for
it's about them it's not about me and
again that comes down to 80 years 20
mouth
um and again I think that's a huge
mistake that I made at the start I was
just talking and blurting out all of
these ideas again to prove to them that
I knew what I was talking about when in
reality that proof came from my
questions rather than
the things that I had rehearsed and
blurted out to them and the rehearse
script that I had about Irving Knight
and why we were amazing when in reality
they don't really care about our new
shiny CRM they don't care about the fact
that I've got 30 000 candidates in our
database in San Diego they don't care
they care about
if I can solve that problem and if I've
done it before more importantly
um so again I think I've been now
weaving previous placements and the
solution that I provided to that company
into my questioning so throughout the
business development call I'm throwing
in oh typically VPS at whatever company
you're experiencing that as well we did
this project for them and it equated to
X solution
um so just kind of involving old
placements to increase the familiarity
and therefore the buying power when you
finish that business development cool
having a more structured process as well
as being hugely imperative for me so
I now have kind of a pitch deck as well
that I've been using on business
development course and I don't know why
but a lot of recruiters don't use
supportive visual material and if you
look at a lot of you know SAS sales
people and Tech sales people who are so
much more developed in terms of their
sales process I think personally than
recruitment they all use material they
all use structure and that's what I've
copied a lot of my learnings from so I
think looking Beyond recruitment as well
for tips has been absolutely fundamental
in my growth so I would highly recommend
that you stalk you know VPS of sales in
different markets besides recruitment
because we can be quite old school
um
last thing as well I used to you know
jump straight into the vacancy I'd be
like hi this is Amber from Irving Knight
seen that you're hiring on LinkedIn what
are you looking for
they're not going to remember me they're
not going to remember that I'm called
Amber they're not gonna know anything
about me other than a voice that they've
heard on the phone they don't understand
anything about my knowledge or my
business you know and so you know
leaving the vacancy part of the call
till the very end that should occupy
such a minimal amount of that cool and
the calls should not be lasting for 10
minutes and you come off and start
headhunting for them how the heck are
you going to know enough about someone's
business and their pain and how to solve
that in 10 minutes you're just not I
typically like to aim for at least an
hour to two hours
um
so yeah they're the main kind of changes
that I've made in in recent years that
have equated in a lot more success
so much value there right we're going to
get a bit more grounding here if that's
okay I just know people are going to
absolutely love this Amber this is so
thank you for sharing this and look I I
can actually really resonate with a lot
that you're saying
um I remember commenting one of your
posts around like the the 30 minutes to
president's Club podcast and like I
learned I take a lot from that the sort
of SAS sales industry and one of the
things that I did over Christmas
was actually take a bit of a step back
and look at how I was positioning the
product that we sell at recruitment
mentors our learning platform and since
putting it into some sort of like
presentation and actually really mapping
out all the problems that we helped
solve uh it's just been way better like
so the whole the whole deck thing that
you just mentioned that's been a real
recent game changer for me
um right now the close rate has been 100
and it just it's all about making people
feel feel stupid saying no to like what
you're um offering on these things but
actually really taking a step back and
understanding the different pens you
actually solved but you're not just
putting a person into a job
um and being really clear on that so
just to get granular a bit here then
there's just two things that I'd love to
just just to sort of focus in on
so the first thing there you kind of
give us a bit of an example of probably
what most recruiters do hey Amber notice
you're hiring a they're probably not
going to be uh advertising the CG on
LinkedIn but hey Amber notice that
you're hiring for this person uh look
that's what we specialize in how you're
getting on with it
is it something that we could help with
let's just say right so you gave that as
a bit of an example would you mind just
sharing what that might sound like now
I know we've got into a bit of role play
Vibes here but I think this would be
really helpful for people and you said
that becomes a real minimal part of it
which I absolutely love by the way and
this is sort of how I approach things so
what what would that initial sort of um
yeah initial part of the conversation
actually now sound like with what you've
tried and tested and found works better
for you
yeah it's a side note quite
controversially
I hate cold calling I absolutely despise
it I never cold call all of my
business schools that I set up are
either inbounds via LinkedIn or I'm
reaching out directly and then we set up
a call so just to premise that I have no
cold call tips because I hate it I hate
being cold so why would I do it myself
um I'm gonna get a lot of hate for that
because I know there's a lot of cold
call preachers out there
um so okay so let's start from the
beginning for example I see a VP of
sales role posted on LinkedIn okay so I
would reach out to the CEO and and say
um hi Tom
um notice that you're hiring for a VP of
sales we've just hired a VP of sales for
X company ideally their competitor
because I work in such a niche area that
typically I have hired for all of their
competitors
um they needed this this was the result
open to learning more so
a low friction CTA is always really
important I think a lot of people will
often say can we chat next Thursday at
2PM when they haven't even said that
they want to chat to you yet so don't
shove yourself down people's throats
when they have an even committed to
interest yet people hate that people
hate to be sold to so don't make it too
obvious
um then when we jump onto the call
I guess the first thing I want to
uncover is you know
firstly why is this a priority right now
what's the trigger
secondly what have you done so far to
fill this role how has that gone what
Avenues have you used have you used
Recruiters in the past what's that
experience been like if they ever let
you down at any point why
um how many CVS do they typically
produce in a week like really get into
detail about
their past experiences with recruiters
because that will often tell you how
open they are to a cell or to a retainer
or to a contingent search and a lot of
what they say in that part will enable
you to solution so further down the line
so for example if Tom said ugh we
weren't retained with the recruiter you
know three weeks ago on this role and
they've not given us any CVS and we're
so frustrated and we never want to work
retained again you should not think oh
my God I'm not going to pitch retain
then that's an absolute opportunity to
pitch retained because you can explain
why you won't do that or you can give
them you know a different option for
example a short list retainer
um which is when you receive the
retainer once you've sent them the
candidates so they've got the
knowledge that you actually have those
candidates in your market so they've got
the security with that
um and and then I think what else is
really important and this is something
that I completely neglected in the past
is how important the close is
because for my team for example often a
lot of the new graduates they'll have
business development calls they'll come
off they'll tell me about how it went
and they're so excited they're so
passionate they you know revved up after
that business development call that went
perfectly then they don't hear from them
ever ever again they never get back to
their emails they never respond
and I just sat back and I thought why is
that happening like I feel and not to
sound big-headed but all of the business
development calls that I've had in in
recent years they typically equate to
business and I thought okay what am I
doing that the team on and they just
want closing effectively enough you know
they weren't ending the call by saying
look is is there anything at all that is
preventing you from wanting to move
forwards with this are there any niggles
that you have about us working together
is there anything that I've said that
you thought
not sure if that aligns with you know
our vision or our mission for this role
and also setting up a second call whilst
you're on that discussion is absolutely
imperative especially if you're doing
exact search for example where CEOs
they're getting 300 400 emails a day
they're not going to be searching for
Amber's email
um so I think closing that and
scheduling another call whilst you've
got their attention is really important
to keep the process flowing
yeah no I think that's that's super
helpful and I think what what I want to
underline there and that I've this is
sort of this light is really what um has
been working for me man or whatever for
everyone but what you're leading there
at the end is a no question
um and you're either gonna get no yeah
there is this that I've been thinking
about or no there is this niggle and
then you're gonna learn more and listen
or you're gonna get no Amber actually
um everything sounds great what are next
steps
right but you're empowering them
you're empowering them to set to
basically be honest with you and say hey
actually no yeah this is these are the
niggles or no all sounds great
um they're in control absolutely and
even at the start so when I first
started implementing more of a structure
I was getting frustrated because I'd get
to the end of my call and I'd close it
and I'd say look are there any
reservations that you have at this time
in regards to working with me on this
project and they'd say no
and then again I wouldn't hear from them
for two weeks so I really had to look
inwards and think are they just saying
no to shut me up I think they are and
the issue was my questioning I wasn't
making them confident enough that I had
the knowledge and the skills to fill
this role so them saying no to
reservations is not always a good thing
and often when someone gives me a
reservation to me I quite like that it's
almost a buying signal because they're
really thinking you know is there
something that she said that I don't
quite agree with and I like the fact
that they're challenging me to me an
objection is a positive because it's
them thinking about actually partnering
with me on this so don't always take the
nose as a negative sometimes it's a
buying signal hey everyone a real quick
one from me this podcast would not be
possible without our amazing podcast
partners vincere and saucebreaker
because you listen to this podcast you
were able to get your hands on exclusive
savings on both of these award-winning
products if you're all a growing
recruitment business you have to check
out Ventura who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with Source breaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
sourcebreaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products okay
and then I think you just spoke about it
there the final thing I just wanted to
zoom on and I think you just touched on
that there was like this process that
you mentioned a few times and how that's
made it more enjoyable for you or I
don't know enabled you to be more
successful could you talk us a bit
through that so when you say process
what we're talking about here we're
talking about Amber's engagement
strategy to take one of Amber's dream
customers or a company that you know
that you're going to be able to help at
the right moments that you want to be
working with in terms of how I turn
Amber from yeah not working with her to
them working with her and providing her
the solutions that you have like what
what does that actually look like when
you said the process
yeah so in terms of the actual BG calls
so I've now conjured up a script over
the years that I like to follow however
I never stick to that script you know
what calls it like they never ever go in
the way that you'd like to plan but at
least for building a team and a
particularly a team of graduates that's
been so helpful because at least they've
got some you know guidelines to go off
but in terms of the process for finding
new clients I'm not sure if that's what
you meant
um
so I'm more of a Cadence type business
developer so again I think a lot of
recruiters are stuck in
the 19 kind of 60s way of recruitment
where you just send out candidates and
hope for the best and yes that
absolutely works it does but that's not
the way that I you know wanted to
approach my business development so in
my market in biotechnology at least
there are different areas within biotech
that I can focus on so for each area
I've got 20 dream companies that I want
to get in with and I'd rather focus on
getting into those companies rather than
just spraying and praying for a result
and I let them know that like they are a
company that I dream of working with
don't be scared to you know show that
passion over email just be like look I
dream of working for you guys I know so
much about you your reputation is insane
and all of the candidates in my market
want to work for you as do I
um so really focusing on 20 targeting
those accounts you know reaching out to
directors VP c-suite if that doesn't
work HR Callen more Junior just really
focusing on specific companies rather
than spraying and praying and hoping for
the best and whilst I think that
technique used to work back in the day
there are now so many recruiters there
are so many technologies that are
personal Brands everywhere and people
who are going to out compete you so you
really need to think more strategically
I think in 2023 you know than ever
before
um yeah absolutely love it so we've
spoken a lot about business development
which I know people love find hard to
get good at so I know that would be very
very helpful for people
I think what else I'd love to sort of
get your thoughts on Amber is
you achieving this uh amazing uh
Billings performance or 780 Grand
what what else did you really have to
work on that you think
enabled you to to hit those sorts of
numbers we spoke a lot about BD that
clearly would have had an impact but
what else did Amber really have to yeah
spend time on evolving improving uh what
limiting beliefs did you have to smash
get rid of what what else did you really
have to work through
to achieve that
my confidence honestly that it's all
boiled down to that and I I'll kind of
backtrack and give you a brief life
story as to you know why I might not
have been the most confident so
you know didn't didn't grow up with a
lot you know single mom living in
Council Flats so my whole childhood I
think we were in you know B and B's at
different times as well and we've always
really really struggled you know with
money and I've never had
kind of people around me to look up to
in terms of ambition and a career and
I've always been really really Money
Motivated and I think that's as a result
of you know struggling as a child and
um my mum said to me that I came home
one day after school this little 12 year
old kind of thing five foot nothing
um
and was like mum I want to try and do an
exam to get into a private school my mum
was like how the heck are we going to
afford that
um but I figured out that they they did
bursaries so got into that and you know
was propelled into this world of wealth
and ambition and motivation and power
and I was just like oh my God is this
how people live they don't worry about
if they're going to be able to afford
their shopping Bill their food bill
every month and I just wanted that
comfortability and you know that's my
driver and I think getting past that
lack of confidence and always feeling
like an imposter at school I felt like
an imposter I felt like I didn't deserve
to be there because we had nothing when
in reality if anything I deserve to be
them you know more than anyone I was
there based on Merit not on the fact
that my dad owned multiple properties
and again limiting beliefs at University
I unfortunately picked a degree that
quite honestly I was just at
um chose accounting and finance because
again I thought right what's going to
get me money being a doctor being a
lawyer being an accountant I was
somewhat good at maths I thought right
we'll give that a stab
so I had the mitting beliefs there
because I was just crap came out of
University
worked in Subway I was lost in getting
imposter syndrome just felt like I
didn't belong to be there for a
completely different reason but
so overcoming you know those limiting
beliefs and just thinking this isn't
down to luck and even when I was telling
you about my first year why am I
describing that as as luck I'm doing it
now even still so
I think just realizing that gets to a
point where Amber where it can't be like
maybe you are just you know quite
passionate and all right at what you do
so yeah I think just overcoming that and
being able to get past that has been
imperative really for my growth and and
getting through those barriers that I'd
created for myself more than anyone
so for someone for someone listened to
this then that that that that will
really resonate with and there'll be a
lot of people that resonate with that
and that story and
um some of the yeah that they know that
they have a limiting beliefs or
challenges confidence issues I'm always
curious to hear what people say about
this like how clearly it's an ongoing
process as you just said because you're
still describing parts of your journey
as as luck
but what what would you share that might
help someone find that inner confidence
more or
become more confident or yeah I don't
know is there anything there that yeah
you think about or could share that
could be really helpful for someone
it's such a
difficult long process and I think
that's what you need to you know remind
yourself these things do not happen
overnight it's taken me you know I'm 28
now and I think I'm slowly starting to
get there but it yeah it's not an
overnight shift and
I think once you
realize that these are only things that
you're telling yourself these are
thoughts these are things that you know
you can control you can lock up in a box
and just forget about them and try and
get on with it I think the sooner that
you realize that the better and again
I've really tried to change my mindset
surrounding limiting beliefs and
imposter syndrome in particular I was
watching um a TED Talk actually I think
it was Michelle Obama talking about you
know imposter syndrome as a female and
Incredibly male
dominated world that she was in and she
sort of said
now whenever I experience imposter
syndrome I love it I thrive in it why
the heck would I always want to be in an
environment that I felt like I belonged
in I'm never going to grow if I
constantly feel like I'm the best most
intelligent most well-spoken most
passionate woman in in the room I need
to feel like an imposter at times
and it for example today I I even felt
like an imposter coming on this podcast
I thought why the heck does anyone care
about you know what I've done but then I
thought no I need to be challenged I
need to be scared I need to do this
because it's going to enable me to to
grow and better myself so it's all
internal and it takes time but you know
the the things that you can do to what
work towards sorry being more confident
yeah no I think just yes his perspective
is powerful right so I think you yeah
you describing yeah I really like that
like why would I instead of thinking oh
this is really bad should I be here
should I not it's like well no why why
would I want to be in a room where yeah
I'm the smartest or I'm not pushed like
it's a positive yeah I really like that
that sort of perspective change
um love Michelle Obama what a woman so
so I definitely want to ask you your if
there's anything to share like I was
honest with you right despite how hard I
try I do find it difficult to
consistently get a good mix of women and
and Men on this podcast
so I guess why don't I just ask you to
ask you this uh now instead of me going
straight into another granular thing
because I wanted to actually around time
management and Day plans when you're
hitting these sorts of numbers because I
know people absolutely love that
yeah so I will ask you but really
quickly as we're talking about Michelle
Obama and you referencing that
what what comes to mind in terms of
people listening to this that may not
have any internal Roy models uh they're
female uh they have no internal role
models in their recruitment environment
uh however they're high performing
they've climbed the ranks but every
single I don't know quarterly board
meeting or leadership meeting they are
the uh only women in the room yeah well
I don't know anything to share this uh
helps you navigate
that navigate the challenges may be the
Amber's faced in being a high performing
female in a recruitment business like
anything to share on there that you've
maybe had to learn the hard way or
things that you
um that might be helpful for people
listening to this that are going through
that or yeah may not have
um women to lean on internally
yeah I think and I guess the issue is is
stemming from the fact that
unfortunately there's still a lot of you
know white collar recruitment agencies
out there with 1950s thinking no female
equal leadership team disparities in pay
no flexible working environment for
women that want you know move on and
have kids
that's where the issue is stemming from
right and I think we're all trying to
move away from that and you and and me
he should I think a lot of us care about
you know changing that reputation and
for example this morning I I had a girl
reach out to me on on LinkedIn and she
sent me just the most
gorgeous paragraph and this is hugely
why I do what I do on LinkedIn and waste
30 minutes of my day writing tips for
for new Recruiters on my LinkedIn page
and she messaged me and she just said
you know hey Amber um
please keep doing what you're doing on
LinkedIn because for me at the moment we
have no female
inspiration we have no one to look up to
I have no wonder to relate to I have no
role models and you know imagine how it
would feel for you Hesham as someone in
in this industry that was incredibly
female dominated and you had no males to
look up to I think you just
automatically think okay well it must be
unachievable for me then they don't have
the setup for me to get to that point
um so yeah that that was a lovely
message to receive and I've received
them way more frequently than I would
like to and whilst it's lovely for my
heart I hate the fact that this is a
recurring issue
um
and yeah I think even in you know my own
company we're really trying to move
towards a more female-led leadership
team and stereotypically I think women
have naturally
occurring attributes that pertain quite
well to recruitment so you know
typically we're slightly more
compassionate we're better listeners and
these are all things that attribute to
an amazing recruiter so why are we not
utilizing that why are we not trying to
get more women into this business but
again I think that stems from the
management team and creating an
environment that feels
non-isolating two women because I think
that's the main issue is it's the
isolation and sense of community but
there's so many communities out there
that you can reach out to like they have
the women's in recruitment community
that I'm I'm part of and just being able
to expand your network and speak to
like-minded Women Within the business I
think you have to somewhat put that on
yourself and create a community if you
don't have that for yourself in your
agency creating that is is really
important
yeah so I guess the insight there then
is yeah go beyond the four walls as you
said if you can't find that Community
internally then there's amazing people
like you that they can connect with or
like go beyond your four walls to yeah
hopefully try and obviously it that
shouldn't only be the case right
obviously we're working towards having
more internal role models and people
that you can see yourself in and make
you feel like things are achievable and
all of that but I guess yeah don't feel
like because you don't have it
internally that you can't get that
externally yeah my diary is always open
for example like I say to you know these
these women I'm more than happy 30
minutes a week if you just want to chat
and run about the things that are
frustrating you that they're not
implementing to make this a more
comfortable environment for women to
work in like I'm always free and it's
not just me there are so many women out
there who I know are willing to do the
same so just make yourself visible and
get out there and by sharing these
stories that we have as well it means
that it's not a secret and we can all
talk about the experience experiences
sorry that we've had and more
importantly move on from those and make
sure it doesn't happen again
so before we go really granted on
recruitment again I think also I think
this is the right moment to sort of ask
you to share your story because we're
talking about more about yeah personally
your own journey and and uh yeah like
those types of messages
just just because obviously we we had
our own experience with this right talk
to me about Amber's genics I think this
could really resonate with people and
might be really helpful
um to hear like talk to me about Amber's
Journey being a type 1 diabetic and
managing I guess life work life
with that like would you mind just
sharing some of those things I think
there will be people listening to this
that yeah maybe on the same Journey as
you but again don't have Role Models or
don't know anyone who has has to juggle
juggle that with work and everything
else so I think yeah this is definitely
the right moment to sort of
yeah have you share anything around that
that you think would help people but
would you mind just talking to us a bit
about juggling uh yeah this condition
that you yeah live with that you have to
juggle with with life yeah absolutely
and
so recruitment we all know it's hard
work right and whilst thinking smart is
important so is bloody working hard and
working hard and autoimmune diseases
unfortunately
often don't coexist and they hate each
other
um so yeah I've been uh type one
diabetic for 22 years now so you know
doing about eight injections a day
trying to deal with maintaining my blood
sugar levels having a life working in
recruitment managing a team being a cat
mum doing it all and so you and I right
we were supposed to meet to record this
podcast and I I just physically could
not make it I'd been up
verb
two hours no I slept for two hours
before the podcast episodes there was
absolutely no way I could string a
coherent sentence together and it's been
hard because the guilt
it's it's really there and I I think
whilst people you know they say that
they accept these differences but I know
that there's been clients in the past
that I've last minute had to cancel on
and they're pissed off at me and I just
think God it's hard enough you know
going through all of this and feeling
this poorly and feeling this incapable
and then you've got people you know on
the other end that aren't being
understanding and it it's really
self-deprecating and I've had a lot of
low moments where I've just felt like oh
my God can I physically do this like am
I you know is my body built to be able
to manage this and more importantly to
be able to not let others down
and for example with the podcast I just
felt awful and whilst you were so lovely
and of course accepting about it it's
still that sense of
I'm letting myself down and more
importantly I'm you know ruining someone
else's time and and their schedule and
yeah it could be really debilitating and
I think again that's why I share a lot
of what I go through on LinkedIn because
I I don't want people to feel alone and
people that can't always put in a
hundred percent and you know wake up and
feel normal like normal people do and
it's really draining and some days I
just want to rip my hair out and think I
just wish I could be like a normal human
with a functioning pancreas because it
would make my life a lot easier
um but again it's the same with um you
know imposter syndrome sharing these
stories is where it begins and if I can
make it seem more normal and
more spoken about then that's a great
place to start
and if I guess just around that thank
you for sharing that and I guess just to
round up I know I'm sure there's loads
of things but I don't know is there
anything that you've found have you
found yourself given
sort of consistent advice for anyone
that uh yeah might be finding it hard to
juggle being a top one diabetic and sort
of uh achieve their work goals or manage
work I know life isn't just work but I
don't know is there anything in there
for people listen to this they're
probably working hard they probably have
a good work ethic is it anything that
you find yourself yeah constantly given
to people that has helped you around
better managing I'm sure you're always
going to have off days as you said but
is there anything that's really helped
you that maybe you could pass on to
people listening to this that's enabled
you to I don't know we could go I don't
know where you could go wherever with
this but I just thought if there's
anything actually practical that's
helped you you know yeah so
there's one moment actually that stands
out
um and my mum just FYI is
my inspiration for everything and like
she is just the most incredible woman
and feminist and independent she's been
a business owner in more recent years
and completely transformed her life and
I remember I was there was one meeting
actually and one good thing I guess
about working in biotech is that people
are generally quite understanding and
I've not had a lot of besides that
CEO that had a go at me but we won't
talk about him
um and my mum once I remember I was
crying to her one day about the fact
that I couldn't make it into work and I
was just so stressed and I wanted to be
there for my team and she just said to
me she was like Amber you don't have to
be everything all at once and I just
remember thinking like
I love that like that really resonates
with me and
it's a big enough stress to have an
autoimmune disease in itself whilst
trying to be top biller whilst trying to
manage a team of seven whilst trying to
be a director and you know have a
strategic Vision on the business you
don't have to do it all no one expects
that from you you're the only one that's
putting this pressure on yourself
um so just focusing on your health your
mental health getting through the day
that's all that matters and sometimes if
brushing your teeth is the only thing
that you achieve
that's more than enough okay you don't
have to be everything all at once and I
think when I'm having those moments I
just remind myself of that in my mum's
voice and everything is better
yeah no I think that's that's a great
quote so less less round off this
conversation then on uh recruitment
let's let's get granular on a few things
okay so firstly right absolutely no no
but these things are important at the
end of the day we're all people so we
can talk about the Grand and stuff but
we've got a Juggle being people and the
different challenges that we have on
these things so they're just as
important but
so I want to know and people will want
to know time management
what does Amber's day look like when
you're hitting those sorts of numbers
that we've discussed like break it down
for us what time are we starting what
we're doing in the first hour two hours
you do two hour Sprints do you always do
two hours of BD do you always do one
hour of head hunting I don't know what
what does Amber's day look like and
maybe let's look at it from the
perspective of Amber only having to
worry about her own performance
uh and not have management one-on-ones
and these types of things in there let's
just go Amber's day plan
being the top Biller
yeah what does it look like sure so I
wish that this reality that we're making
up existed because obviously there are
random meetings shoved in everywhere and
you know Amber can I quickly borrow you
for this
um
and quite honestly time management is
naturally not a strong point of mine and
it's been something that I've had to
consciously really consciously work on
um and this had to be a lot of
techniques that I've consciously had to
put in place because I'm someone you
know my brain goes at three million
miles per hour and I'm working on
something and then an idea Pops in my
head and I'm like this with with
flicking between projects and I think I
did a post about time management
actually today
um but in terms of my day plan
it's not structured I used to time block
which I loved whilst I was a individual
contributor but time blocking does not
work if you are a manager so but if you
are you know just trying to be top
biller I'd really recommend breaking
down your days the night before is
really important as well so always plan
what you're going to be doing the next
day the day before so you can just
offload you can go home and leave the
office with a clear mind you know
exactly what you want to achieve when
you come in at nine o'clock the next day
and you can just get going with it
um so yeah time blocking's been
incredible
however I can't really use that now
because it just doesn't work
um batching as well is is something that
I've implemented to later on in my day
so for example at the moment I've got
you know 12 roles that I'm hiring for so
that can get quite overwhelming so just
focusing on one role each day or between
each kind of set of time has been really
helpful too rather than putting 10
effort into one project then flicking
onto the next one 10 minutes later
that's been really important I mean in
terms of my day plan
I wish I had a set amazing shiny
laminated day plan to list off to you
but I really don't I've never been a
structured day plan kind of person
however one thing I do always stick to
is doing my business development first
thing in the morning and eating the Frog
so for me the Frog I.E the task that I
hate doing the most is business
development
um not having the calls but you know
doing the prospecting and the messaging
and writing the LinkedIn post that's my
least favorite thing so why do that
first thing in the day so that's out the
way I've done it I've got no excuses it
doesn't get to 5 p.m and I'm like oh
I've not done my BD today I'll just do
it tomorrow it's already done in the
morning so eat the frog has been a great
bit of advice and that was from um 30
minutes to president's Club as well
which you mentioned earlier
so yeah I love that less about the plan
and more about Frameworks and uh
mechanisms that help you get the most
out of the day or give you a better
chance of yeah getting the most average
day yeah and prioritize effectively and
I've just got to figure out you know
what works for you because everyone's
mind works in completely different ways
and what might work for me would not
work for you the next person on on my
team so I think listening to these
podcasts seeing how top billers plan
their day trialling it for a week and
just seeing what works for you
um so one or two more things here then
as we come to the to the end so I yeah I
think it'd be really unfair of me not to
ask you
um how Amber is because I've seen you
post different things here but I think
one of the posts I've got up here
around no it's it's a good thing so I
think you put on there around like I
know we spoke about this in preparing
for this and you've clearly said on this
podcast how important building your
brand from the the beginning has been
really impactful so I think you put on
here around like yeah 80 of your leads
come inbound right so let's just talk
about this for a sec like for someone
listening that would love to be in that
position
like where what what what are the
principles behind getting to that point
that you've implemented like I think
you've yeah I think you've spoken about
not even in sales calls where this sort
of uh uh is probably worth thinking
about and applying the same thing as
like it's less about Amber and more
about them right but what else what are
the principles to like that you've sort
of yeah really worked on behind getting
to that point where you are getting a
lot of your business inbound and what's
enabled you to remain consistent with
with your brand
I think really defining what brand meant
to me
because you know the majority of
recruiters are just posting job
descriptions or roles that they're
working on that's not their brand that's
not them that's not their personal brand
that's just them posting roles that's
not going to show a potential client
what you're about what your ethos is
what your values are that's just job
descriptions
um so really defining what what a brand
means to you and I think
the most valuable bit of advice although
it's quite obvious is is just start just
start just start writing it does not
matter if you get one mic or 1 000 likes
who cares you have to
it up to figure it out in a
roundabout way
um
and writing as you speak I think is
something that people need to remember
because you know with my team for
example I'm a huge advocate for LinkedIn
posts and building your brand and you
know we've had times where I've sat them
down at the end of the week and I'm like
guys why has no one done a LinkedIn post
this week and they're like oh we're just
not good at it like you am but we're not
good at writing and I think I'm not good
at writing I'm literally just writing
what comes out of my mouth and you know
sometimes I'll even send voice notes to
myself of ideas that I've got and then
I'll type out the transcript and that's
my post you don't need to have all of
these you know connected further molds
and
um connective words that's not what is
interesting short and snappy copywriting
is what sells
um if you look at all the the biggest
you know LinkedIn accounts they're
people that share stories that are
people that share personal experiences
they're people that share learnings
they're not people that share facts and
Figures it's actual personable relatable
content
so just starting is my biggest bit of
advice and second thing that I think is
imperative that people don't think about
enough so
consider how people are on LinkedIn
typically right it's their phone so when
you're scrolling on your phone the only
thing that you see on each LinkedIn post
is the first line that's it and the only
things that I click see more on and
engage with are posts where the first
line hooks me in so if you have not
mastered that first line the rest of
your post is pretty much pointless so
smash that chat gbt or GPT or whatever
it's called exists now that can
literally write you hooks exciting hooks
ask it and post it it's not difficult
now there are no excuses so just start
posting and see what happens like what
is the worst that could happen
you're not going to die from a from a
LinkedIn post so just give it a go
yeah I think it's really interesting I
was speaking to
um just my girlfriend about this just on
the weekend because I helped her dad who
they've recently relocated to Wales and
us and so they're now I want to get back
into work but part-time and he's been
applying for jobs and these things and I
helped him write his cover letter and
his cover letter was like what you'd
expect it was like I'm determined to do
this I'm a great team player like just
the Classic basically like all the
stuff that people think you need to put
in there
and I was just saying like being able to
write is such an underrated skill and
tool that you can use in so many
different parts of your life but
particularly recruitment I think it's so
overlooked like actually just investing
in time like thinking about how you can
get better at writing and it does come a
lot from doing but sort of labeling
yourself not a good writer you're never
gonna obviously become a good one but
I'm such a huge advocate of using a tool
called grammarly like either everything
that I write goes in grammarly and and
has run through that then it's just
simple things like you've mentioned
Amber around getting better at talking
about things from the other person's
perspective it's not like remove their
eyes from your vocabulary you said it's
all about you and getting in that
person's shoes so if you combine the
Curiosity and really trying to pick up
and be interested in the nuances of your
market and what people are saying and
the common themes that you keep uh tend
to hear and then writing about the
things that you pick up on like it's
just such a powerful thing so being able
to help yeah my partner's dad with a
cover letter where it went from oh my uh
like yeah I'm a great team playing all
these things to then it sort of sounded
like you're probably going to look at my
CVV and tell me that I'm too experienced
for this job let me tell you why I'm not
like it's just a it's just a whole it's
such a valuable skill set that people uh
Overlook I think so I'm glad that you
highlighted that
um absolutely so
does he want to add something to that
sorry no I was going to say um no I
completely agree and I love that you
brought up that point I don't think I
would have been top biller if I hadn't
focused on my copywriting skills like
I've been reading so many books about
copywriting and concise language and I
think as well so for example in in the
markets that we serve it's all executive
so it's all you know CEOs of big
companies and you would think that those
people would respond well to really
intelligent eloquent language but they
don't you need to mirror the way that
they speak to you and CEOs when they
message me they often don't even bother
saying hi Amber like they just say what
they want full stop best regards Tom
that's it and my team would be you know
like hi Tom hope all is well in your
world just wanted to check on the status
of our proposal if you've got any
questions just let me know you know
always happy to reduce our fee rate if
you need me to no mirror the way that's
they speak to you hi Tom have there been
any progress internally regarding our
proposal thanks Amber
it doesn't need to be long-winded and
wordy that does not equate to
intelligence okay being concise and
direct and asking for what you want will
um so yeah love that you brought up that
point because it's definitely something
and I'm going to start implementing this
I think into my interview process is a
task surrounding you know writing so
that I can see how good people are
because like you said it's just
completely imperative in recruitment
and I think this leads quite nicely on
until where we're going to sort of wrap
up here and then I'm definitely going to
end with
Amber's sort of maybe best books that
you've read or yeah things that have
really sort of helped you because
clearly you've mentioned a few different
things here but it was actually a post
that I commented of yours okay and
hopefully you're willing to share
you might know what post I'm on about
you shared a screenshot
I might have missed the post where you
share that you said he was going to but
anyway you like this is this is a
screenshot of the message we're talking
about writing here and we've all learned
how Amber's approached things and I
think there's there's like I'm not
surprised that you're achieving the
things that you're achieving absolutely
love your mindset the weather you're
approaching things you're open to
learning these sorts of things right so
this screenshot says hi Amber thanks to
your message honestly we have uh
committed to not use agencies at least
for the remainder this year and we are
confident that we do have the capability
to meet our goals with that in place
however
I just wanted to say that this is the
best intro email I've ever received from
an agency
brackets quite refreshing
we'll definitely keep you in mind if
things should change appreciate it
so obviously the the sort of thing that
we've learned here right is you're
saying recruitment's a long game
I want to be memorable be yourself like
although I've got a no here uh I've
definitely stood out right so Amber may
have an opportunity to work with this
dream uh client in in the long term
what we're doing in this uh intro
message Amber what are we saying
right so this
so this company is you know one of the
biggest companies in my market and I've
been trying to get in with them for
about five years I'm not gonna lie
um and finally I've got a BD call with
them now next Tuesday so we've finally
got there five years later persistence
is key guys
um what did I write in that email that
was the question I have to think
um
intro email may we can go don't have to
be that specific message but what yeah
what what does Amber put in that intro
emails because clear I'm sure you have a
bit of a framework at least yeah so
typical framework for intro emails short
Snappy personalized trigger warm CTA so
I don't know why I keep using Tom but
let's just pick Tom VP of sales at
biotech company so I've just seen that
Tom's done a YouTube video about their
funding and what they're going to be
spending it on so I would
use that as my intro or you know I've
noticed that Tom has hired six sales
reps over the past three years and I
know one of them I would use that name
in the intro and similarly to LinkedIn
where that first line is imperative it's
the exact same with emails because when
they come up either on your laptop
screen or your computer screen or your
phone the only thing that you see is
that first line so you need that trigger
to be in that first line that is
completely important if you've not done
that you're likely not going to get an
open
um so always use that trigger first
second line is always
the problem so you know an issue that
people within that space are typically
having so I don't know VPS of sales in
my market right now are really
struggling because they all have to have
phds or Masters and there's not enough
of them so I'd say that problem that
shows them that I know the industry I
know the market I know what the key
hiring problems are right now next line
tell them about a similar company that's
had that problem and how you solved it
next line open to learning more or just
kind of some form of cold sorry warm CTA
um so not high can we chat next Thursday
at 2PM just open to learning more or if
you ever thought about this is this a
priority for you right now just
something a bit warmer
um so that's the general structure and
you've just reminded me I need to post
that email actually so maybe I'll do
that tomorrow so look at my LinkedIn if
you want to see that guys yeah no
absolutely love it
let's end on let me you've mentioned a
few different things but let me let's
just end on I don't know maybe top one
to three books that you've read that
have had a real impact on New York
clearly someone that's passionate about
self-development which I absolutely love
and yeah there might be some books that
people can put on there to read list
after listening about your journey yeah
what once free books have had a real
impact on you maybe mindset just
recruitment in general personally what
comes up
yeah so
time management is not my strength in
either as memory so I know the names of
the books but I often don't know the
authors but the classic that everyone
always says but it is just a brilliant
book it's never split the difference
that's the the best the best book for me
in terms of negotiating these things
absolutely completely changed my mindset
regarding negotiation and just
recruitment in general if you've not
read that read unbelievable it has to be
read yeah the best book I've read
um regarding you know copywriting
emailing content is by Nicholas Cole and
if you don't follow him on LinkedIn he
should you should and the book I think
is called um the art of the art and
business of online writing it is oh I
haven't read that ah it's
okay
online writing yeah Nicholas Cole and I
can tell how good a book is by how
highlighted it is and honestly I must
have highlighted every bloody sentence
in that book it is
insane if you want to get started on
LinkedIn you know like I said my biggest
tip is just get going read that book
um and it's not very long short and
sweet big letters it's the nice read
um so that'll be my second third one for
women in recruitment in particular
is called how women rise again not sure
who the author is but I'll figure it out
and why can't I can't do that now so
we've got Nicola Nicholas Cole the art
and business of one I'm writing I'm
definitely going to order that and you
said women rise you just said how women
right so how women rise so basically
there was this book written by some
dudes I don't know some white 50 year
old men somewhere and um it was all
about the you know the characters and
attributes how women rise break the 12
habits holding you back that's the one
you've got it
um so yeah that book that the two dudes
wrote was all about attributes and
characteristics that make up successful
leaders and entrepreneurs and these
women were reading this book and it was
just completely written with males in
mind it was written from a male
perspective they were typically male
attributes and so these women thought
screw that we're gonna write our own
book about how women can rise and become
successful leaders within business and
it is so good and refreshing and it
makes what's cool about it from what I
can say sorry to button is it's written
by Sally helgasin and also a guy called
Marshall Goldsmith so they obviously
combined put their heads together I
think for me it just made me feel less
alone because again often these
experiences aren't shared and I used to
think am I just making this up in my
head like this gendered disparity or
this discrimination that I'm facing not
in my work right now but just throughout
life or is this actually happening and I
think that book
just narrated all the thoughts that I
was having and really made me feel like
I was less alone so that was amazing
again a really nice read to give that a
shot if you're a girl in recruitment
love it yeah I'll put those
um links to the books and stuff in the
in the show notes but look Amber thank
you so much
thank you it's been uh for being uh yeah
nothing short of yourself open honest
shared so many great things there I
would not be surprised if you get
inundated with messages saying how
helpful it's been I think kudos to you
on consistently investing in
yourself your own development because I
think it's for me after getting to know
you even more on this I'm not surprised
at all with the things that you've
achieved so far and no doubt the things
that you're going to achieve in the
future So yeah thank you so much for for
coming on the Pod thank you Hesham I
really appreciate it thank you so much
for listening to the episode I hope you
enjoyed it and got value from the
conversation if you did enjoy it please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and we'll see you in the next episode